hey everyone welcome to led live how
much money
is enough money to make you happy find
out on this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness welcome everyone
to led live we're so glad you could join
us on another episode we're excited to
present
the last part in this it's kind of a
series you know
that we've been doing talking about the
lust of the flesh the lust of the eyes
and the pride of life and so we're gonna
dive deep into that today i also want to
thank our patrons you guys are the ones
who
help make this channel possible if you
don't know anything about patreon
we can put something on the screen to
direct you just go to patreon.com look
up little light studios
or check out the link in the description
below it'll take you right to it and you
can find out
by supporting us you get all these cool
perks some donors they get
exclusive t-shirts some get digital
download dvds
you get exclusive behind the scene
access all kinds of stuff so check
patreon out
here are some of the stickers that we
have if you want more you can check it
on our website
and you know by purchasing this stickers
you also help us
toward making more of this video free on
youtube so check us out
you could have a whole outfit going on
because it's good
there you go yeah or they could go on
here like this water bottles
they look great on water bottles that's
right
these are like three bucks on our
website we ship them free so
check those out we do have one bumper
sticker it's a little more money so
you might check that one out jesus makes
america great it's awesome right
i love it he does okay we also have
t-shirts tell us about t-shirts scotty
t-shirts we make t-shirts to help
support our ministry we actually really
uh like the idea of just creating an
opportunity for you to share your
witness
and t-shirts is a great sort of a voice
that maybe
you don't say the words but it's printed
on your shirt
and you know we also have not just
t-shirts but you can get
sweatshirts sweaters socks iphone
kit um cases you name it if you click on
the little link called teespring right
below the video here
you can see an endless things that you
can put these different graphics onto
and pretty soon we'll have actually a
t-shirt operation of our own
back on our website which actually
really helps us more and and gives our
ministry more of the funding
which helps us create more projects so
if you guys want to help support that's
a great way to do that
and we also have a spanish channel but
we're
going a little bit further tell us about
that candy yeah a lot of you have
reached out to us on our social media
platforms or sent emails
really wanting to get the little light
studios
episodes the message the gospel out to
people
who don't speak either english or
spanish people want to hear
these messages in their native tongue so
we have
listened and put together little light
studios
international channel on youtube it's
very much community based
it it relies on the submissions of
people who either want to
well all of our videos are open to
subtitling but some people have reached
out saying it's better to dub
the videos so people can listen and not
just be reading all the time
so if that's something you're interested
in if you speak another language
other than spanish or english and you
would like to help us out
reach out to us on on facebook instagram
little studios that tv and um let's
let's help that channel to grow so more
people all around the world
can enjoy little light studios
productions and i think we've actually
had quite a few of our productions in
different languages i mean i've
i've seen from french russian german you
name it like
translated actually dubbed over as well
so if you know
of anybody that's already done the work
or you know of any channel send us a
link or something
so that we could actually offer that on
our little light studios international
channel as well
and bless many other people who have
different languages
all right so we've been talking about
the verses from john chapter 2 verses 15
through 17 which talk about
the lust of the flesh the lust of the
eyes and the pride of life and today
that's what we're going to talk about
we're going to talk about
the pride of life and we've been having
this theme that we've been talking about
moving from devotion to
desire and that is what this world is
geared to that is what satan is
trying to get each one of us to do is
move from devotion
to desire and so
what we need to be focused on is what
does god want what does god want for our
lives
so today's topic the pride of life
the more we are transformed into these
other images that we're looking at all
the time
the more i think that can easily turn
into self-defense
okay because we're trying to maintain
that image
and then we oftentimes thirst for more
greater aspirations of what that looks
like and that means
less dependence on god
so i want to show you guys a few
articles today one is from
psychology today this is eight crucial
differences between
unhealthy and healthy pride and i'm not
going to go through all of those i went
through this and
picked out a few that i thought were
relevant so here it says
that unhealthy pride
depicts an overtly favorable evaluation
of self based on giving oneself too much
credit for accomplishments that
typically
are rather modest such as overvaluing
one's abilities or achievements
and can relate to attributing oneself
success that belongs as much or more to
others involved in whatever task or
project was successfully completed
okay so real word example i don't know
if you've ever watched football before
but you know if a team is doing really
bad who's fault is it
it's the coach or the quarterback you
know it couldn't possibly be the whole
team
right right and so what do they do they
cycle out the coach they cycle out the
quarterback and it's like okay now
everything's better
now granted those are positions of
leadership and they're important but
you know is it really only attributed to
tom brady for example like is that it
what it's talking about here when it's
talking about unhealthy pride is what we
would simply call pride
in the bible right so this is coming
from a secular source we've got to kind
of keep that in mind
but notice how it says in overly
favorable evaluation of self
based on giving oneself too much credit
or accomplishments that are typically
rather modest aren't we good at that
aren't we good at being like
man i did so good pat myself
don't break my arm you know patting
myself on the back i call them attaboys
yeah it's so easy to
lift yourself up or inflate your
abilities or you know like yeah i did
that or that was all me
or what have you when really you know
you don't get through life
without other people helping you like
even from the very beginning like
you had to be born and somebody had to
take care of you at some point
right here's another point on the
contrary unhealthy pride
is far more aggressive and explicit
it's a declaration not only of
competence as such but
of personal superiority it frequently
takes on the form of looking down on
others
or putting them down i mean that's how
you get to the top right
you got to step on everybody all the way
up
and if you want to make yourself look
better you see people do this to make
themselves look better they have to put
everybody else down
around them which you're not really
raising the standard
you're just lowering it yeah you think
about it my
son he's eight years old um actually
experienced this the other day
he was over at a friend's house and
there was a lot of other friends that
were over there
and um it was a it was a new house that
they had just been in
and one of the little boys had never
been there before and he walked into the
little kid's room
he looked right around and he goes why
is your room
terrible like that and my son was just
like
why would you why would you say that it
impacted him enough to come home and
talk about it and he brought it up and
he said that was really a strange
comment that he made like
like he'd never been there before why
would he say his room was terrible in
his room
they live in like a brand new house and
so i had this conversation with him i
said you know sometimes
when people feel um you know like
threatened or something they'll tear you
down
so they feel better about what they have
and perhaps maybe this little boy that
made that comment
doesn't have the same kind of thing so
he wants to feel better about his own
stuff making fun of the other boy you
ever heard that my dad can beat up your
dad
yeah yeah that's another one i gotta
teach my kid that
all right here's another point this
article brought out it says
on the contrary unhealthy pride links to
what is generally deemed
antagonistic anti-social or
rule-breaking
behaviors what's interesting is you look
at those qualities
and i find that at least a couple of
them is exactly how the bible describes
the fallen angel
from heaven lucifer right he was a rule
breaker
says this in isaiah it says in verses 13
and 14
of chapter 14 for you have said in your
heart i will ascend into heaven
i will exalt my throne above the stars
of god i will also sit on the mount
of the congregation on the farthest
sides of the north i will ascend above
the heights of the clouds
i will be like the most high now
this is what we call an eye problem
right
not this eye problem but a me problem
right everything about himself in this
passage
is being elevated above everything and
everyone else
right so lucifer's appetite for more
it never ends he's always got to have
more he believed that being beautiful
actually if you read the text closely
entitled him to mourn
i'm so good-looking right that's why i
deserve all this
just like we see people who are
beautiful today and they think more
highly
we think more highly of them sometimes
because of the halo effect right
this happened within himself with the
halo effect going on inside
you know looks at himself sees himself
man i deserve so much more
you know does fulfilling our desires
make us
happy that's a great question what do
you guys think
on the surface yeah i think it depends
on what your desires are
if you have healthy desires you know and
and like i desire to be more healthy
individual i want to run
i want to eat healthy i want to do these
kind of things right if i fulfill those
activities
i'm generally going to feel better but
if you have unhealthy tastes
then i think it's damaging yeah i think
it depends also on the motive
do you want it more like selfish thing
or for
helping other people that's actually a
good point because
you can actually use health even working
out i used to work at a gym
and i mean you see those guys just in
front of the mirror all the time you
know
which way is the gym so
uh it can be an unhealthy thing to be
healthy like that too yeah i can
so typically when we think about this we
think about it in the worldly
perspective right and
and the worldly perspective says if i
have more
i will be more happy okay all right
a bigger house a bigger bank account
whatever it is
certain features of your body
accentuated
a better education whatever it is as
long as we have more of it
i'll be satisfied have you guys ever
known anybody really really really
really wealthy
yeah and did you ever spend a lot of
time with them
i mean like enough to know like you know
would were they generally happy
oh no i've actually only been
friends with somebody that that would
quote unquote be you know extremely well
off
and they said that it was very fearful
like you constantly have this anxiety
people out to get you out to get your
money you may lose it you may you know
there's a lot of
like that old saying there's more more
money more problems
yeah i i have nothing to compare that to
because i've never been in that position
but
um yeah sometimes i don't envy the uber
wealthy
is that why you said one time that you'd
want to be a undercover wealthy person
that's right that's right
i would live the same you know find out
who to like support and give money to
and i would never tell them
millionaire next door what is desire
let's take a look at this article i
think this is from the huffington post
it says our desire points us outward to
the world of
objects it suggests that our anxiety
is created by not having something and
we talked about that earlier
how the world is this does this good job
of creating this
emptiness you know so that it can be
filled says a job a relationship a
shopping spree
and that if we were to just fill this
void we would be happy you know
fill the hole if we were interested in
resolving this anxiety
as quickly as possible we might turn to
the most obvious solution
which is to give our desire the food it
is asking for
when we sat when we satiate our desire
we receive a taste
of happiness the desireless
state this lasts only
until we feel another void
right which triggers another anxiety and
another desire
and so on and you can see
it doesn't it it just keeps going and
going and going and this is one of the
ways the advertising industry works
right
they have to create a dissatisfaction
within you
in order to be able to fill it and then
they're constantly creating
dissatisfaction so they can heal the
they can fill the hole
that they created even when you're
wealthy
there's always someone more wealthy you
know what i mean like you can
like see there's levels even within that
and and there's there seems to be no end
to that
satisfaction right so
here's another this is an interesting
perspective now this is coming from a
secular news source so they're drawing
from
all kinds of different people this
particular spin that they're put on
is actually a hindu perspective but
having said that i think what they're
saying is true
okay so listen to this as we grow
spiritually
we begin to want less for ourselves
personally and care more about the
welfare
of others it is not that we stop taking
care of our own
mental and physical needs but that we
realize the chasing of our personal
desires does not lead to the freedom
it seems to promise when we realize this
we naturally lose interest
in fulfilling every personal desire that
crosses our minds
so very insightful i think it's true
i'm not suggesting that hinduism leads
to happiness
i think that kind of happiness is only
found in christianity
in jesus but i do believe
that what they're saying is true
specifically in that
in the right context yeah when you're
accepting
um to kind of
make it broad like a higher power but
for us would be jesus christ
a savior outside of yourself there's
just this contentment yeah
that you feel and yeah as they're saying
like of course you're going to
be passionate about things and go after
things but it's just not your
drive anymore right i think it's true
because
you're not serving yourself anymore and
i think that is just
a principle that god has set in motion
you know serving yourself doesn't lead
to happiness but serving other people
does so if you find that same principle
in other religions i think it
it really started with you know god and
but you know other things have found
that that is true it's just a
principle of life we see this in genesis
3 5 it says for god knows that in the
day you eat of it your eyes will be
opened and you will be like god
knowing good and evil right notice what
satan is doing here
he's creating a void where none really
existed we talked about this
on the last show in this series was
there any reason
for eve to be insecure no
no there wasn't right he was exploring
something that was good for her
to desire to be like
uh god and to have knowledge these are
good things right there's nothing wrong
with that
but anything she wanted to know all she
had to do was
ask god right and
she was already like him in the respect
that she was made in his image
so if she wanted knowledge she had the
ultimate source of knowledge at her
disposal
already just ask whatever you want to
know just ask
right but now think about this
this is um this is a really powerful
insinuation that he makes here with this
verse
eve do you really want to be like
someone
who is withholding do you really want to
be like someone who is
keeping something good from
[Music]
yeah do you really want to be like
god and then he's
really insinuating you could be like god
apart from god and really fulfilling her
desires
did not make her happy
yeah immediately i can imagine that she
went back and
maybe had a little bit of an argument
with her husband
you know yeah like like especially a
little bit of a kind of a quarrel and as
that first time
i mean you can tell the effects were
immediate
so i'm actually working on a sermon for
church for this but
um the the ideas i'm kind of tracing
this through the bible is
is if you think about it he's implying
that there is a good gift
that god is not willing to give now
follow that line of the reasoning all
throughout scripture
then she takes what she thinks is the
good gift and she goes to
offer that good gift to her husband
right and then after everything falls
apart
right the wheels have come off the train
you know
obviously the husband doesn't appreciate
the gift he was given both
relationships the relationship between
man and god
is broken the relationship between man
and man is broken
right so which is why it comes in later
when jesus
talks about you know love god with all
your heart mind strength and your soul
and your neighbor as yourself
right it's because that's what was
broken in the beginning and
so if you think about it god
is now in this position where he has to
prove
that he will not hold any
good gift and so what links does god
have to go to
he has to go to the ultimate gift the
old like this is the best thing i could
ever give and i'm going to show you i'm
not going to withhold it
wow so that's really what's behind
all of this uh insinuation that the
devil is really getting at with eve
so let's look at a few more studies
harvard study says that the key to
happiness
isn't fame or fortune it's not
you saw it has anybody here ever thought
about being rich
have you ever seen that clip from jim
carrey that says i wish everybody could
be famous for a little while just to
know that you don't want this
right wow take a walk in my shoes yeah
you know and i think that if you could
experience it for a little bit you'd
probably be
more content with what you have so i
think we can all agree we probably all
thought about being rich at some point
right
uh my my personal fanny is fantasy is
like having my own personal island right
being able to go there any time um
but if you were rich what would you do
with the money
right now give it away really
i mean maybe i'd
just a few things yeah but i think i
think there's there's a blessing in
giving
and i've seen people that have been
really uber giving with like
generous hearts and you see something in
that
that that god is is pronounced i mean
doesn't the bible say
it's better to give than to receive
right and i think that if you really
understood that principle i think
there's
an amount of satisfaction in giving i i
heard on the radio the other day um do
you know who chikowski is
the piano player tchaikovsky
you tell how much i listened yeah i
listened to uh classical music
but they were talking about it i was
listening to classical music and um
they said that there was a woman that
when he was in his 20s and 30s
that um contacted him and he was kind of
floundering around
wasn't able to really make ends meet and
she said i will take care of your money
until the day
you are you're done you will have a
check always
to do this but i have one rule you can
never see my face
and so through his whole existence
he created music and somebody funded him
and he never
met her except for on his deathbed the
lady showed up
wow and it was a very wealthy lady and
she said
i have invested a lot in you and i can
see that my investment was well worth
everything that i paid into it wow and
she
had this little just pleasurable um
thing where she just was was helping
this one person create
you know resources for people to enjoy
and i just think that's so neat like you
know if i was wealthy i would love to do
something like that where just
you know they don't they don't even know
right yeah
having a lot of money it sounds great
right i think we can all agree on that
but
according to this study it suggests that
money and fame do not fulfill our
happiness what do they mean by that
a long-running harvard research team
suggests the most
important predictor of whether you live
a long
and happy life isn't related to the
amount of money you'll amass
or the notoriety receive but how you get
on
with your loved ones so it's
relationships
it is relationships so a huge punchline
right
it's your relationships and if you look
at the world today nation after nation
culture after culture home after home
humanity is just a
string of broken relationships
and i don't think there's a lot of
people on their deathbed
that when they're recounting their
regrets they're saying
i wish i would have bought another boat
i wish i would have bought another house
i wish i would have bought all these
other things i think a lot of them are
regretting
i wish i would have spent more time with
my kids i wish i would have spent more
time with my spouse
more time with my friends you know
because that
they can see at the end of the day is
what means something
towards the end of this article it says
this something as simple as replacing
screen time
we're in favor of that with people time
or livening up a stale relationship by
doing something new together
like long walks or date nights i need
more date nights
i can tell you that right now so
spending time with people
and you know what's really amazing this
is where the wisdom of god
shines god built this into humanity from
the very beginning he set aside the
seventh day
of the week for relationships for
spending time
with people and you can see that in the
sabbath commandment it comes from exodus
10 and 11. so i'm not going to read that
but you guys can look that up dwell upon
it think about it
it's very very relational and it's about
the relation between
man-to-man and god demand right the
thing that was broken
in the garden of eden how you think
about money this is from uh
cnbc i think how you think about money
can impact
how happy you are in life the study says
so did you know that there is a number
the magic number at least in the us i
don't know what it is for other
countries okay
this is the happiness number for money
okay one
million dollars okay what's your guess
michelle uh more than one million not in
a lifetime like something like what you
have right now
oh annually yeah maybe 100 300
no 100 grand 300 grand what do you think
let's go five five hundred hundred
thousand dollars yeah
well you guys are like high high rollers
it actually turns out it's not that high
so a princeton study in 2010
found out there's a correlation between
happiness and wealth
to a point of about seventy five
thousand dollars per year
i won you got the closest when people
make
more than seventy five thousand dollars
a year their happiness
doesn't increase but the lower the
income
is the worse they feel the study found
out so you can't be more miserable
making less money
for sure but you can't be any happier
according to this study
by making more than that and if i think
about it and i think you know
i think you know of course this number
is
it could change from year to year decade
decade you know based on inflation
and you know cost of living and all that
kind of stuff but if you think about it
the number is it's like
it's enough to take care of my needs and
my family's needs
i have a little bit extra to do things
that i would enjoy
i have enough extra that i could be able
to help somebody and give
i can save but it's not so much money
that i'm paranoid about maintaining it
or
somebody's gonna try to you know off me
to get my money
or steal from me but anyway having more
apparently will not make you happier so
this is from mark's psychiatry
fame money beauty do not bring happiness
okay what does it have to say in this
article
the things that make you happy in life
are growing
as an individual having loving
relationships
and contributing to your community so
there you go
they're in agreement right reinforcing
the earlier point happiness is about
relationships
it's not about your bank account they
said the greatest satisfaction came from
the achievement of intrinsic goals such
as personal growth
building relationships improving the
community and physical fitness
that met the basic psychological needs
of autonomy
competence and relatedness
yeah i mean i think that there's a
there's a simple
amount of of things that are within
everybody's means that can make you
happy sure i mean
everybody can have a have a relationship
if maybe not a spouse
or or you know someone of the opposite
gender
you can easily have a church family or
you can have friends or neighbors or
whatever
and you know it's amazing if you're
friendly to people
how much people will be friendly back to
you you smile at people how much people
will smile and respond back to you
that's what the bible says right he who
desires to have
friends must be friendly inc magazine
said this
harvard's study of 4 000 millionaires
revealed something surprising about
money and happiness
they found that if you want you and your
heirs to be happier
you should give your money away and let
them make it on their own
wow wait wait
sorry so let me get that straight give
all your money away but let who make it
on your own
your kids let their kids make it on
their own that's that's
exactly what um steve jobs wife is doing
yeah that that's do you know what our
name is no
this will show you it's uh lauren
powell jobs actually everybody on this
list bill and melinda gates warren
buffett
mark zuckerberg mckenzie bezos george
lucas sting jackie chan elton john
gloria vanderbilt andrew lloyd webber
ashton kutcher gordon ramsey lord and
pal jobs
michael bloomberg all these people
they're like we're giving our money away
so if any of you guys listening are one
of these people
and you would like to give to our
ministry
now in some cases it's all of it like
warren warren buffett's like really
strong on this he's like my kids aren't
getting a dime
yeah like the most i will do is give to
a charity in their name that's
fine they have his knowledge they have
the name
that'll be fine yeah yeah other people
are like that's probably true
you know the gates aren't quite that
harsh they're like we want to give them
enough
that they can have a good start and
enough to do something
but not so much that it's like a waste
you know and that was like jackie chan
you know that's what he said he's like
the way i'm looking at it is like if my
kid isn't responsible
with my money i would be ticked off to
leave it to him you know
[Music]
that list goes on ted turner philip
seymour hoffman aaron spelling james
brown
gene simmons oprah pierre oh
um omid dayar and bernie marcus pierre
is the co-founder of ebay and bernie
marcus is the co-founder of home depot
so here's a question then do you think
that the people i mean these people are
all names that we've probably heard half
of them right at least or we use their
products or services
and do you think that they realize that
money corrupts oh yeah
i mean at that top level are they
literally like
the reason why i wouldn't pass down to
my kids it'd be like passing on a curse
to my children you know what i mean
i mean that's a good point we're just
about to get into uh
why they're not satisfied with their
will all these people
um have recognized there's something
about wealth that they don't want to
pass all that to their kids came across
something in the atlantic that says the
reason
many ultra-rich people aren't satisfied
with their wealth you would think if i
just had more if i had all this money
i'd be satisfied i mean i could buy
anything that i want right anytime at
least had 75
grand yeah i don't know like we know
that we're in ministry
so here's what it said
what drives people once they've reached
that point
to keep pursuing more this is the
question what
what drives them why do they want to
keep going after more and more and more
and the reason is um they're asking
themselves questions
am i doing better than i was before and
am i doing better than other people
right that's what they're asking
themselves that's what they're asking
themselves
and here's the challenge um a lot of the
things that really matter in life
according to this article are hard to
measure yeah
if you think about it right so if you
wanted to be a good parent
it's a little hard to know if you're
being a better parent now than you were
a year ago
like how do you measure that right and
it says it's also hard to know if you're
a better parent
than the neighbors how would you know
right you just you just know like what
your experience is
you might talk to other parents and find
out you're not alone
you know their kid acts up so does yours
but
how do you know if you're a better
parent well they go on
it says because you don't know the
answer to these questions right
so people turn to dimensions of
comparison that can be
quantified how do i know if i'm doing
better money
is a terrific one the author of this
article says
if i need to know if i'm doing better
than i was
the easy way is to ask am i making more
money
or does my house have more square feet
or do i have
more houses than i used to
right you can measure money that's easy
but you can't measure some of these
other things in life so we just kind of
default to what's easy to measure
and we use that to drive you know
whether or not we're being
successful so that makes sense
he also said the instinct is to measure
and to compare
it doesn't disappear once people have an
obscene amount of money
the problem is am i doing better than i
was is only moving people
in one direction up
right that's the only direction you have
to go you can only go
up no there no other
way to measure that and then they say
the sensation of being well off talking
about somebody that they were writing to
an
email is not about fulfilling a
childhood dream of buying
a sailboat or something feeling wealthy
is about a comparison
with others in your reference group so
the question is not what individuals
want to buy but what they feel they must
buy
in order to keep their status
so have you ever heard of keeping up
with the joneses oh yeah
apparently that does not stop even if
you're uber wealthy
yeah no because there's always someone
more wealthy than you and better stuff
and
bigger houses and play toys yeah so am i
doing better
i don't know like am i making more money
is my house bigger i mean that's that's
how you're measuring it what's
interesting is like i love technology
like
i i actually have to stop myself from
obsessing over technology and i've
really fallen in love with apple apple
has taken lots of my money
and you know have you ever bought a
phone and you you're so excited about
the phone and you're just like this is
the best phone ever and then a month
later you're just like
you do the same three things right like
six generations ago did the same thing
that this phone does it's just like why
did i need
but it has a better camera i need this
one and so i i
i can identify with that just you know
it seems like when you achieve what you
get
it's not the thing that lasts you know
it's not the most fulfilling
so have you ladies heard of cameron diaz
yeah
okay do we have to ask because on the
last show i was like cindy cropping
you're like who's that
so i'm going to show you a clip from
cameron diaz who is
a very successful actress you know she's
made lots of money she's been in lots of
films i want to hear
i want you to hear what she has to say
about happiness
okay okay when people say oh i want to
be like you want to be an actor
i want to look like you the question i
always ask them is why
like really why and people
and especially america this idea of fame
that
to be famous means that you're
successful that you you're happy
it's not about i don't do what i do
because i want to be famous
that's part of being famous is my job
that's
i am not when i'm home i am not and i'm
with my family and my friends
i am not famous i am me and i'm
cameron and that doesn't fame does not
define
me and so if you are looking for fame to
define you
then you will never be happy and you
will
always be searching for happiness and
you will never find it in fame
and so it goes back to
i think for me authenticity intention
why do you want to do
anything you do it should not be
motivated by
something that you think is going to
make fulfillment comes from within you
by being authentic to yourself not
chasing fame
wow i i like the idea of being authentic
i really do
like i appreciate people even if they
have a different point of view
than me as long as they're owning it and
and you can tell like that's really
their you know
you know and they're doing it in a nice
way or whatever like that's like a
difference of opinion
but i suppose you could be authentically
satanic
you know what i mean or whatever that
doesn't mean that's necessarily good
just because you're
authentic to yourself i don't know if
that would be the end-all be-all of
of happiness if if that makes sense yeah
i think i know what she's getting at but
yeah kind of her comments toward the end
i don't know that i would 100 agree with
that you know that it's all about within
you and all that i think it's
from god having a relationship with
jesus but
um i get what she's getting that you
know is not cracked up to be
what it what everybody thinks it is and
the little amount that i spent in
hollywood and the few celebrities that i
really did know
i mean that that was literally what i
found out was that
you see it on the outside as something
totally different as on the inside
and it's just not the same it's a
fantasy that they're selling to everyone
and when you get inside the fantasy it's
like this is it
you know it's like what yeah that's the
wisdom i was given in high school
in choosing your career pick something
that you would do regardless of whether
you're being paid or not
and that's what um that's more that's
the thing that you would get into and
probably last a lot longer because
you're enjoying what you're doing
if you're going in because of the fame
or the money i mean
that that's such an emotional
rollercoaster that you probably just hop
off i actually heard a podcast that's
like
uh review uh what we do this like three
things as a job
as a career or as a calling so if we
view what we do as a job yeah it won't
really make you happy because you will
be focusing on the money
if we view it as a career may make make
you happy because you will focus on
more on the development of your skill or
whatever but if you view it as a calling
you will focus on uh
doing it because you believe that that
will
fulfill your happiness that will help
people that's good
yeah chris rock has a comedy bit on that
he's like
you know i got a career a lot of you see
a lot of you have jobs
like you're waiting to clock out this
ain't really work though this is not
really work this is my
career you know some people have jobs
some people have
careers that's right because when you
got a career
there ain't enough time in the day there
ain't enough time
you got a career you look at your watch
time just fly's like whoa
it's 5 35 and i got to come in early
tomorrow work on my project
because there ain't enough time when you
got a career when you got a job
there's too much time that's like you
look at your watch like ah 908
then it's just like such a joy to me
that it doesn't feel like work
that's a career like all of you should
have careers it's like yeah that's true
that's that's how actually i feel with
ministry i mean um
you know just being in it for so long
it's like i thrive off of
like new and inventive ways to try to
like share the gospel and like
um i lay at bed thinking about it a lot
and it's
not hard for me to want to come to work
you know i'm not dragging my feet going
i don't want to be here
this is a joy let's take a snapshot of
some famous people
and see what they have to say about
being
famous this is daniel radcliffe you guys
have heard of him right
harry potter harry potter he'll never
get away from that
the good place right yeah yeah the good
place
if you haven't seen the good place
there's a reason youtube shut that video
down that we did on the good place so
you guys need to go to patreon.com and
find that
we have it up for free um he said the
quickest way to forget about the fact
that you were being watched was to get
very
drunk then as you get very drunk you
become aware oh
people are watching more now because i'm
getting very drunk
so i should probably drink more to
ignore that
not a good philosophy that's a pretty
bad
space to be in i don't i don't believe
that the human being
was meant to have so much attention on
you
and that attention is stressful over the
course of of an amount of time
especially
if you you you became very famous as a
child like this
he does not he grew up in it so he does
not know what it's like to be normal
it's kind of like michael jackson to me
is is is an example of be someone who
reached the top of fame and look how
strange he
he you know ended his life and i think
that's just a testament to
we're not meant to be worshiped we're
not meant for people to to do this and
it's real easy to just
check out of that because you can't
handle it and you're not meant to handle
it
even the um attention we get on this
show can be
somewhat uncomfortable people will make
comments and be like why don't you look
happy
i don't understand like you look angry
or you're quiet today or
what have you i mean it's weird just to
see the comments that people will make
about you right in the youtube channel
um
even that can be unnerving and
uncomfortable i remember
we just put out this instagram video for
our t-shirts and somebody was like
commenting on how that was like
really out of place for me to be
you know like in the commercial and like
i guess happy goofy or something mercy
and so um
right gigi hadid
do you know who this is yeah yeah okay
do you know supermodel
still okay here's what she said it's all
right
i've lost a lot of friends because i'll
get
busy for a short period of time and
they're not reaching out
but if i don't reach out then it's like
i've changed
i'm good with the friends i've got
i wonder too if there's a level of
intimidation too i mean not only is she
pretty but it's like now all of a sudden
you have she's a supermodel
i mean i'm sure maybe she gets random
phone calls from all the guys that want
to like hang out with her but
you know maybe she's speaking in terms
of of a girl maybe girls just feel more
intimidated being around or so
yeah yeah i i really really seriously
think
like being famous is a lo can be a
lonely life
i'm sure your friendship circle just
like goes like this because no friends
not everybody can relate to you anymore
right i guess that's why there's such an
appreciation for day ones
because those people who with you before
all the fame are now with you after
they're able to just
the consistency it's refreshing right
yeah and you know why they're there
yeah because they would have been there
you know even regardless yeah right
idris elba no no
oh yeah okay it's an up-and-coming star
they've actually considered him for the
new james bond role but that's him and
half a dozen other guys
um he said this sometimes you're not
sure
what's real or not especially when it
comes to relationships
and how remember how we've been talking
like relationships is kind of like the
key to life and here they are in these
positions of fame and they're like
i don't even know if my relationships
are real if you're adored by millions
sometimes
even when you're on your own
front doorstep you can become paranoid
and constantly question
who is he who is she i know i've been
guilty of it in the past
wow that's scary yeah i mean just not
knowing people's intentions
i mean i can only imagine that's what
really really wealthy people feel as
well
you know i don't like the feeling of
being around people
especially if i know you know we work in
a ministry and and sometimes you know
there's a balance between needing to ask
for help for certain things and
i don't like to be around somebody and
then i'm thinking
they're thinking that i'm thinking about
their money you know what i mean
it's just like i hate that feeling yeah
and i can only imagine being famous like
that you have no idea why people are
really there yeah you know especially
even
you know male female relationships like
does that person really care about who i
am or do they only care about what comes
along with it you know
which is why prenuptial agreements exist
right right right and why probably many
marriages don't exist because you
attract
such a wrong type of person megan fox
i'm sure we've all heard of her right
i've heard of her
i've heard of her yeah who's that no
jerking okay
what people don't realize is that fame
whatever your worst experience in high
school
uh when you're being bullied by those 10
kids in high school fame is that
but on a global scale wow where you're
being bullied by millions of people
constantly
i i i see that we you know the little
amount that we've been
i don't know if i'd call it bullied but
people that like like
really are maliciously rude on our
commenting
and things on our on our channel right
if you had that
times you know 100 million
you that may play with your head a
little bit you know if you keep hearing
people all the time and
and she i remember had a bit of a
problem in hollywood because
there was a dis like a dispute between
her and
the director of the transformers michael
bay michael bay and
then that word got around that she was
just difficult to work with and nobody
wants to work with her and so then
you've gotten to this place you've
gotten one little piece of fame and then
now no one wants to work with you
and maybe she's like that maybe she's
not i don't know but the words that
people said about her
damaged her her ability to move forward
in in that
and then um yeah it's just like these
people struggle with more than you you'd
think
like it looks glamorous to us but you
have no idea the depression the
you know anxiety that these people
handle is
magnified i think president obama did
something
pretty smart when he was in office he
didn't watch the news
yeah you know he didn't turn it on to
see what they were saying about him
on you know all these nightly television
shows or the networks or whatever he
just he didn't watch it
because i think it helped him focus on
his job uh
if you were just drinking that on all
the time it would just do damage to your
mental state like oh they're saying this
and all they're saying you just be
agitated all the time
you just say it's fake news big news
[Laughter]
sorry i'm leaving that in for sure
all right george clooney he says the big
house on a hill
is isolating there is no other way to
say it
there are restrictions to this kind of
fame i haven't walked in central park
for 15 years
i'd like to you know yeah the view is
only nice for so long
yeah yeah it's a fishbowl you're in a
fishbowl would you like to live in a
fault small fishbowl
i feel i have that feeling i love fish i
have that feeling towards fish
and birds i literally love it but a bird
in a cage to me
is like oh like i want to fly so bad
that would just be
such a joy and here we took this
beautiful little animal and we put it in
a box
and we won't let it fly around and i'm
sure that's just
exactly what this is like yep
selena gomez my self-esteem was shot
i was depressed anxious i started to
have
panic attacks right before getting on
stage
or right after leaving the stage
basically i felt
i wasn't good enough wasn't capable i
felt i wasn't giving my fans
anything and they could see it which i
think
was a complete distortion what i wanted
to say
is that life is so stressful and i get
the desire to just
escape it all right so as we're wrapping
this thing up you guys can see that
here's a whole bunch of famous people
and they're
they're stressed you know in some ways
depressed
they're looking at life you know like
scotty said from a fishbowl
perspective it's just like there are
things i can't do
there are relationships that are broken
i have paranoia it's not all it's
cracked up to be
and they have lots of money right and
money does not equal their happiness
i just want to close with a couple of
thoughts from luke 18 this is the story
of the rich young ruler
now the point is to not to criticize
people who have wealth that's not
what i want to do with this but to just
reinforce
uh people we've been talking about okay
so here it says in luke 18
18-21 now a certain ruler asked him
saying good teacher what shall i do to
inherit
eternal life so jesus said to him why do
you call me good
no one is good that is god you know the
commandments do not commit adultery do
not murder do not steal do not bear
false witness honor your mother and your
father
and he said all these things i have kept
from my youth
so when jesus heard these things he said
to him
you still lack one thing so all that you
have
and distribute to the poor and you will
have treasure in heaven and come follow
me
but when he heard this he became very
sorrowful
for he was very rich wow you know that
that's really interesting
because at that point see when you have
that much wealth following those other
commandments gets increasingly difficult
first off your focus is on this wealth
and trying to manage it and trying to
protect it from certain people
that it gets hard to honor your parents
because now you're like second guessing
like with their intentions it gets hard
to love your neighbor as yourself and
all these different areas even to love
god because
now you're like you're getting this
impression to do certain things when
you're like wait but that's going to
mess with my finances and it's just
the whole thing yes it's possible but it
gets more difficult so i see
you know i'm sure jesus had so many
angles to this but one of them is
you know redirect your focus all of you
so all you have and follow me
and see how much see how invigorating
that will be how easier it would be to
follow the commandments to take you to
another level yeah
you know as you were reading this verse
something kind of jumped out at me that
i haven't really thought about it as
before either when he said you know um
good sir right and he says why are you
calling me good right
nobody's good but god i've always kind
of read that like like
almost like like don't call me good you
know what i mean
but it's actually more like he was
giving him a window into you just called
me good and the only person that's good
is god
i'm god it was like an interesting way
for him to reveal
to him that he's god and then
he literally is giving him the answer to
eternal life
because if you could ask god how do i
get there and god answers
and isn't that amazing that even though
he let the guy know
that he was god he still walked away and
you could also see how holistic it is
jesus wasn't a billionaire millionaire
did he even have 75 grand i don't think
so
[Laughter]
um the bible says he was lowly he wasn't
you know attractive physically and all
these things
yet someone was able to look at him and
say good you're good
yeah you know just having that peace in
christ you will get
everything that you need not necessarily
what you want but all your needs will be
covered
people will be able to look at you and
see christ amen you know
how cool would that have been to have a
chair made by jesus
right oh yeah like a piece of furniture
or something like this right
and i can just picture jesus walking
over to somebody's house and
and exchanging the chair for money right
i'm sure that's probably how he
supported himself in his teenage to
college age range right
yeah i'll make you a chair it'll cost
you you know 30 bucks and i wonder if
the thought went through his head
as he's given it you know i made the
wood
oh my goodness wouldn't that be amazing
to follow
the line i would love to see a piece of
video like where those articles ended up
and how well-made they were and how long
they lasted and yeah
wow interesting time would be awesome
well this man he walked away from what
could have made him
truly happy and really if you think
about it
the invitation that jesus was extending
this guy
to this guy was to be a part of his
inner circle
and follow him around i mean that's
that's that's huge
this guy might have healed people
he might have written a book of the
bible
right he might have lived forever
but he brought he bought into the idea
that
the temporary things of this world were
more important
wow you know and jesus wasn't saying
sell your things
and then bring your money and join us he
clearly just was like give it all away
and then come and join us you don't need
any of that
we don't need any of that just come and
be with us right
yeah cool yeah it is a cool dog jesus
wasn't asking him to give him all the
money
right yeah he wasn't like wow you're
wealthy you could you really help our
operation
didn't say that at all so in all of this
these past three
presentations that have been done um i
guess what my
my end thoughts are that we should put
our
focus on preparing for heaven not the
temporary things of this world not the
lust of the flesh not the lust of the
eyes not the product of life
and if we look at all three of those
temptations really
it's satan trying to change
our desires trying to move us from
devotion to desire right that's really
been the theme throughout this whole
thing
and so our desire
i believe should be to serve jesus
so amen you want to be careful what you
put into your life what you allow into
your life what you
allow to have influence in your life
right
whether it be people whether it be money
whether it be movies whatever it is you
need to be careful what you
uh let influencer will influence your
life
and ask yourself is it worth the cost
all right is it worth it uh the things
of this earth
really are empty and disappointing
but that's something that jesus will
never be
so you guys have any final thoughts you
want to share
i don't know i just remember the story
of nicodemus somehow
you know how he was the son he did son
he joined right
yeah and he was looking for jesus
but he was too scared of the opinion of
his fellow son hidrian he didn't end up
following him
just imagine if he did that's really sad
that he was pretty instrumental after
the death of jesus right yeah
and so you know i think that's also neat
that that
you know god didn't just say well you
had your chance like the
the other guy what's his name pilate
pilot
he ended up lost yeah can you imagine if
pilate would have like given his heart
to god and all of a sudden he's in
heaven and
you know it's like you could meet the
guy that like made the call
literally to kill god like yeah
it lets you know that they can be used
people who are wealthy can be used it's
your focus like who is in your heart
yeah i don't think that god is saying
you cannot be wealthy
right i just think he's he's he's given
a cautionary tale
of saying this is going to be difficult
for you to continue in this line
with this because of the way that the
world treats wealth and stuff
um but there are as many wealthy people
that that give
you know to all kinds of different
organizations and pieces of god's work
and you know i'm sure god has put them
in that position
to really help work the move stuff
forward as well so
the funny thing is he's dumping it right
back into their pocket so it's just like
this cycle
it's awesome yeah wealthy or not famous
or not
the point is what's your focus and do
you have a great relationship with jesus
and if you do
all right and you keep that up it's all
good well thank you guys for joining us
on another episode of led live we
encourage you guys to
keep watching don't forget to like
comment and subscribe we want to hear
your guys's feedback
and all this and we really appreciate
how you guys keep coming back week after
week and we hope that you will share
this video and the other videos
and share it with somebody that it will
impact their life
because we want to see people change and
we want to see people
make it to heaven that's what it's all
about so thank you and we will see you
on the next show take care
[Music]
you